The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ROBERT FIELD: Today, I'm going
to go over a lot of material
that you already know
and work an example
with non-degenerate
perturbation theory.
This will give me an excuse
to use interspersed matrix
and operator notation,
and one of the things
that you will be doing is
dealing with infinite matrices.
And we don't diagonalize
infinite matrices,
but the picture of
an infinite matrix
is useful in guiding intuition.
And so we have to know about
what those pictures mean
and how to construct them from
things that seem to be obvious.
OK, the problem I want to
spend most of my time on
is an example of a real
molecular potential which
is quadratic but with a cubic
and a quartic perturbation
term, and this is a
simpler problem than what
I talked about last time.
The last time I
really wanted to set
the stage for what you
can do with non-degenerate
perturbation theory,
and this is going
to be more of dealing
with a specific problem.
Now, the algebra
does not get simpler,
and so it's easy to get
lost in the algebra.
And so I will give
you some rules
about what to expect, when you
have a potential like this,
and how does that come out of
non-degenerate perturbation
theory?
Now, everything that
we know about molecules
comes from spectroscopy.
That means transitions between
energy levels, and so well,
how do they happen?
And we can lead
into that by talking
about the stark effect
which is the interaction
of an electric field with
a dipole in the molecule.
And so most
transitions are caused
by a time-dependent electric
field which somehow interacts
with the molecule through
its dipole moment,
and so you'll begin
to see that today.
Last time, I
derived the formulas
for non-degenerate
perturbation theory.
Now, I'm a little bit
crazy, and I really
believe in perturbation theory.
Most of the textbooks
say, well, let's just
stop here at the
first-order correction
to the energy levels,
and you get nothing
from that except
the Zeeman Effect
which is kind of
important for NMR.
But in terms of what molecules
do, you need this too,
and this is equal to
the zero-order energy.
I'm sorry, the
zero-order energy which
comes from an exactly
solved problem
and then the diagonal matrix
element of the everything
that's bad in the world,
the first-order Hamiltonian.
And then, we have this
complicated-looking thing,
m not equal to n of H n m
squared, E n 0 minus E m 0.
Now, the only thing
that you might
forget about in this
kind of a formula
is is it n before m or
the other way around?
And what we know is, OK,
here is the nth level,
and here is the mth level,
and the interaction causes
this level to be pushed down.
So if the mth level is
above the nth level,
this denominator
will be negative,
and that causes
the pushing down.
And so if you remember the
idea of perturbation theory--
that things interact, and
one level gets pushed down,
the other level gets pushed
up, equal and opposite--
you can correct your flaws of
memory on which comes first.
And we can write
the wave function
as an eigenfunction of
the exactly solved problem
plus a term, m not equal to n of
H n m 1 E n 0 minus E m 0 times
psi m 0.
Now, the reason this sum does
not include the nth level
is, well, if you did, this
denominator would blow up,
and you don't need the nth
level, because you've already
got it here.
So these are the
formulas, and we had said,
OK, we're going to write the
Hamiltonian as H0 plus H1,
and this is an exactly
solved problem.
This is everything else.
Now, some people will sort this
out into small everything else
and big everything else.
But it's foolish,
because all that does
is multiply the algebra
in a horrible way,
and you don't care, anyway.
You just know that this stuff
that's not in this exactly
solved problem
gets treated here,
and you're going to know, in
principle, how to deal with it,
and there'll be
some small problems
that you know how to deal with.
OK, and there is a rule that
H n m 1 over E n 0 minus E m
0 absolute value is
much less than 1.
That's what we mean.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Are you making
a deliberate choice
to put all the badness in
the first-order perturbation?
ROBERT FIELD: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Then, what
goes into higher order,
if we make that deliberate?
ROBERT FIELD: OK, you
can say, well, we've
got things that are
important, that obviously
affect the energy
levels, and there's
things that are smaller,
like hyperfine structure.
And when you use the word hyper,
you generally mean it's small,
and so what ends up happening
is that you do the big picture,
and then you see
some more details.
But it's only a
very small number
of people who actually
segregate the badness
into real bad and not so bad.
OK, so this works only when
this off-diagonal matrix element
is smaller than the
energy difference,
and that's going to be true.
Now, here is an infinite
matrix, and we're
interested in a certain
space, a state space, which
our experiments are
designed to measure,
and it depends on what
experiment you do.
This might be here,
it might be somewhere
in the middle, and the
rest, we're not interested,
because it's far away.
Because the energy
denominator is so large
that the effect on the
energy levels can be ignored,
or you can say, well, we're
not really ignoring it.
We're folding the effect
of all these levels
through the matrix
elements in here
into here by second-order
perturbation theory.
We could in principle do that.
We certainly are
allowed to think
that we are getting rid of this
state space by, in principle,
folding it into this block.
Now, in this block of
levels that we care about--
now I always like to draw
these infinite matrices,
or these matrices,
by just saying, OK,
here's the diagonal.
And there might be a couple of
levels within this state space
we're interested in
which, because of accident
or because of something evil,
their energy denominator
is small compared to the
zero-order energy differences.
But that's usually true
for only a few accidentally
degenerate states,
and we deal with them
by using the
machinery we obtained
from the two-level
problem, and so there, we
are actually diagonalizing
a small dimension matrix.
We're not diagonalizing it, our
computer is diagonalizing it.
You really don't
care how it's done,
because you have a
machine that will solve
this like difficulty, and
so it's OK for this rule
to be violated.
But so what happens, suppose
we have two levels, and--
I just want to make sure
I use the same notation
as in the notes.
So here, we have the
two zero-order levels,
and they interact and repel
each other equal and opposite
amounts.
And these states, which are E2
and E1, are not pure state 2.
They have a mixture
of state 1 in them.
Now, in spectroscopy, we
always observe these levels
by transitions.
And so suppose we have
state 0 down here,
and let us say that this
transition between the zero
level and the zero-order
level 1 is allowed.
I'll symbolize that by
mu 1,0 is not equal to 0.
And the transition between this
level and this zero-order level
is forbidden, mu
2,0 is equal to 0.
So we call this a dark
state and a bright state,
and now these two
states interact,
and we have mixed states.
So the real eigenstates,
you wouldn't
have expected to see this
level in the spectrum.
But you do, because it's
borrowed some bright character
through the perturbation
interaction,
and so there's two surprises.
One is everything is sort of
describable by a simple set
of equations, and then there's
a couple of deviations,
and there's some extra
levels that appear.
That's information very
rich, because if it's dark,
you can't see it.
It's not a ghost.
It's there, but
you can't see it.
Well, the perturbation
somehow pulls--
sometimes-- pulls
the curtain back
and enables you to see stuff
you need to know about.
Now, you can imagine exciting
this two-level system
with a short pulse
of light, where
the uncertainty broadening
of the short pulse of light
covers these two eigenstates.
What happens then is
you get quantum beats,
and that's going
to be on the exam.
OK.
So this is a local perturbation,
and it's just something in here
that spoils the general rule
but it's very information-rich,
and it also is
pedagogically fun.
OK.
So now, I'm going to talk
about stuff that I've
talked about before,
but I'm going
to go a little
deeper and slower,
and so let's do this problem.
We have a potential,
and for molecules, we
tend to use Q rather than
R or X as the displacement
from equilibrium.
The harmonic
oscillator coordinate,
and it's the same
thing and so we have--
OK, so this is an
exactly solved problem,
and this is something extra.
And so this is a
cubic anharmonicity,
and this is a quartic
anharmonicity.
In the previous
lecture, I talked
about anharmonic couplings
between different modes
of the same polyatomic molecule.
Here, this is really
a simpler problem,
and I probably should have
talked about it first.
But I didn't, because
I want to go deeper
here than the big picture,
which I described last time.
So we're going to
have two terms that we
are going to treat by
perturbation theory,
and there are several
important things here.
Molecular potential looks
like this, not like that.
Right?
This is bond breaking, and it
breaks at large displacement.
There is no such thing
as a bond breaking as you
squeeze the molecules together.
So this is a crazy
idea, and how do you
get an asymmetric potential?
Well, it's cubic, and which sign
of b is going to lead to this?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ROBERT FIELD: Right.
OK.
Now, if we're really naive, we
say, yeah, negative is good,
but boom, we ignore that.
We don't worry that, if
we took this seriously
at large enough
displacement, the potential
will go to minus infinity.
We don't worry about tunneling
through this barrier.
We just use this to
give us something
that has the right
shape, and that we can
apply perturbation theory to.
And we're not going to worry
about using perturbation theory
to capture this tunneling,
at least not now and not
in this course.
OK.
So one thing is
we have this term,
and there is something you know
immediately about odd powers.
They never have delta v
equals 0 matrix elements,
they never have
diagonal elements,
and so they do not contribute
to the energy in first order.
The only way you know the
sign of this perturbation
is from a non-zero
first-order contribution,
because when you do second-order
perturbation theory,
the matrix element gets squared,
and the sign information
is lost.
So there's nothing
so far that tells you
what the sign of b is, and the
energy level pattern that you
would obtain from either
sign of b would be the same.
It's just one of the signs
is completely ridiculous.
Now Q to the 4th has selection
rules delta v of 4, 2, 0,
minus 2, and minus 4.
So that delta v of
0 term does enter
in first-order
perturbation theory,
and so you can determine the
sign of any even perturbation
which is useful.
Now, what does this do?
Well, one thing that Q
does is, if c is positive,
instead of having a
harmonic oscillator,
it makes it steeper.
And if Q is negative,
it makes it flatter.
This is typical of
bending vibrations,
and so bending vibrations tend
to have flat bottom potentials,
but there there's
also something else.
Suppose we have two
electronic states.
Now, I am cheating,
because I'm assuming
you'll accept the idea
that there is something
we haven't talked about yet.
But there are different
potential curves,
and it's mostly true
for atomic molecules.
These two states can't
talk to each other
at equilibrium,
because a symmetry
exists that prevents that.
And as you move away
from equilibrium,
there's a perturbation that
gets larger and larger.
And as a result, what happens
is that this potential
does something like that.
So you get either a flattening
or an actual extra pair
of minima, and this
one gets sharper.
That's called a
vibronic interaction,
and that's fairly important
in polyatomic molecules.
But so we can begin to
understand these things
just by dealing with these
terms in the potential.
OK.
So now, we're off to the
races, and my goal here
is to make you comfortable
with either the operator
or the matrix
notation, and so I'm
going to go back and forth
between them in what might
seem to be a random manner.
OK.
Now, you know that a dagger.
Now, we can call it
a dagger with a hat,
or we can call it a
dagger double underline--
bold, hat, matrix, operator.
And you know that
this operates on v
to give v plus 1 square
root psi v plus 1,
or in bracket notation,
we could write this as v
plus 1 a dagger v.
Now this is a shorthand.
It's a wonderful shorthand.
It's easier to draw this
than wave functions.
But we have to
know, OK, what does
this look like in the
matrix for a dagger?
So here is a dagger, and it's a
matrix, and what goes in here?
Well, the first thing
you do, this is infinite,
so you need some sort of
a way of drawing something
that's infinite so that
you understand what it is.
And so the first thing you do
is you know that there is no--
all of the diagonal
elements are 0.
Now, most of the elements
in this matrix are 0,
and you don't want to draw them,
because you'll just be spending
all your time writing 0's.
So we want a shorthand, and so
now this is a matrix element.
This is the row, and this
is the column, and so where
do I put this square
root of E plus 1?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ROBERT FIELD: So
here, we have the row.
I get confused about
this, so before I
accept your answer,
which I want to reject,
I have to think
carefully about it.
So let us say this is 0, and
this is 1, so we have the 1--
you're right.
OK, and so we have
the square root of 1,
the square root of
2, square root of n.
And everything else is 0,
so we can write big 0's.
So that's what this
matrix looks like.
Now, if we're using computers,
instead of multiplying
these matrices to have
say Q to the 13th,
or a dagger to the 13th, you can
just multiply these matrices.
That's an easy request
for the computer.
It's not such an
easy request for you,
but you end up getting matrices.
When you have integer
powers of these,
you get a matrix with
a diagonal and then
another diagonal separated by
a diagonal of 0's, and so you
know what these things
are going to look like.
So you might ask, OK,
what does a look like?
And there are
several ways to say
what a is going to
look like, because it's
the conjugate
transpose of a dagger.
Well, these are
all real numbers,
and so all you do is flip
this on its diagonal,
and now you get a.
Then there's another
actor in this game,
and that's n, the
number operator,
and the number operator
is going to be a, a dagger
or is it going to be a dagger a?
So which is it?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ROBERT FIELD: This.
ROBERT FIELD: Yes.
OK, one way to
remember this is when
you operate with
either a or a dagger,
it connects two
vibrational levels,
and the thing you put
in the square root
is the larger of the
two quantum numbers.
OK.
So what would the number
operator matrix look like?
So what do I put here?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ROBERT FIELD: But what's the
lowest vibrational quantum
number?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ROBERT FIELD: Right.
OK, and so once you've
practiced a little bit,
you can write these things.
And it's not just
an arbitrary thing,
because you want to be able to
visualize what you're doing.
Because you're dealing with
multiple infinities of objects,
and you want to focus only
on the ones you care about.
And with a little bit of
guidance from these pictures,
you can do what you need to do.
OK.
Well, we know what
the operator Q is
in terms of a
dimensionalist version of Q,
and that's h bar over-- now,
I'm going to be using this.
OK, this is the
dimensionalist Q.
That's what the twiddle means,
and these are constants.
And now I'm using omega twiddle,
because spectroscopists always
use omega in wave number units,
reciprocal centimeter units.
Which is a terrible thing,
because first of all, wave
number doesn't have a unit.
It's a quantity.
And centimeters are things
that we're not supposed to use,
because we use MKS.
But spectroscopists
are stubborn,
and when we observe
transitions, we always
talk about wave
numbers not energy.
And so the difference between
wave numbers and energies
is the factor of
hc, not h bar c.
So anyway, this is the
conversion factor, when
omega is in wave number units.
And we can go further and
relate Q twiddle well,
let's just not do that.
We can relate this
to h bar over 4 pi
c u omega square root
times a plus a dagger.
OK?
So this is something
we did before.
Omega twiddle is k over mu
square root 1 over 2 pi c--
hc.
So this what you're
used to, and this
is the extra stuff that we
have to carry along in order
to work in wave number units.
OK.
So we have operators
that can be expressed
like a, a, a dagger, a or a
dagger, a, a, a or anywhere you
put the dagger anywhere.
You look at this, and you say
immediately I know two things.
I know the selection rule.
The selection rule is count
up the a's and count up
the a daggers, and so this
is delta v of minus 2.
So is this.
All of the positions of the a
dagger are delta v of minus 2,
but the numbers, the matrix
elements, are different.
You know this from
the last exam.
So we can have v minus
2 v and whatever comes
in here in one of those forms.
So those are the only
non-zero elements,
and you know how to
mechanically figure out
what is the value of
the matrix element.
Now, in order to simplify
the algebra, which is not
essential to the physics, you
want to take all of the terms
that results say
from Q to the 4th
and arrange them according
to selection rule.
And then take all of the terms
that have the same selection
rule and combining them
to a single number.
And you use the
computation rule to be
able to reverse
the order of terms.
Well, I don't want to do that.
So suppose we have an a,
a dagger, and we can write
that as a, a dagger
plus a dagger, a.
And so if we want
to convert something
like this to
something like that,
we know that this has a value
of plus 1, so we can do that.
And that's tedious,
and you have to do it.
But one of the things
that is kind of nice
is when you have
a problem that's
cubic or quartic or quintic, you
mess around with this operator
algebra once in your life, and
you put it on a sheet of paper,
and you refer to it.
It doesn't matter
what the molecule
is, what the constant in front
of Q to the 3rd or 4th or 13th
is.
If you've done the operator
algebra, you're fine.
Now, you might say, well,
I don't want to do that.
I'm going to have
the computer do that.
Well, fine, you can have
the computer do that,
and then a computer will tell
you what the matrix looks like,
and you can do what
you need to do.
OK.
So spectroscopists call the
vibrational energy formula
G of v. I don't know why
the letter G is always use,
but it is, and so
this is the same thing
as vibrational energy.
And the vibrational energy, I'm
going to put the tilde on it.
You will never find a tilde in
any spectroscopy note paper.
We assume that you understand
that the only units
for spectroscopic quantities
are reciprocal centimeters,
but for this purposes,
I have finally caved,
and I said, OK, I'm going
to put the tildes on.
So the energy levels, now
you might ask, why this?
This is the first
anharmonicity constant.
It's not a product
of two numbers.
It's just what people
wrote originally,
because they sort of thought of
it as a product of two numbers,
but it's really only one.
And that's times v
plus 1/2 squared,
and then the next term is
omega e, ye, e plus 1/2 cubed.
So this is a dumb power series
in the vibrational quantum
number, and so in
the spectrum, one
is able to fit the spectrum
to these sorts of things.
So that's what you
get experimentally,
but what you want
to know is we want
to know the force
constant, the reduced
mass, the cubic anharmonicity
constant, the quartic
anharmonicity
constant, and whatever.
So these are
structural parameters,
and these are
molecular parameters.
People like to call them
spectroscopic parameters,
but that implies something
more fundamental.
These are just what you
measure in the spectrum.
And so we want to know the
relationship between the things
we measure and the
things we want to know,
and so that's what
perturbation theory is for.
OK.
Now, to risk boring
you, I'm just
going to go over material
that we've done before.
So if we have Q
to the n, we have
this constant out in
front, h bar over 4 pi c
mu omega twiddle to the n over
2, a plus a dagger to the n.
And so we're going to
be constantly dealing
with terms like a
plus a dagger squared
and plus a dagger
cubed and so on.
These are the things I said
you're going to work out once
in your life and
either remember or just
become so practiced with
it, you'll do it faster.
And so these contain the
values of the matrix elements
and the selection rules.
OK.
So I'm going to do an
example of the cube,
and that's, of course, this
thing in constant the 3/2
and then a cubed
plus a dagger cubed
plus a whole bunch of
terms which have two a's
and one a dagger.
So let's just put it a
squared and a dagger.
This isn't a computation rule.
This is just three terms
that you have to deal with
and three terms that have
a dagger squared and a.
So that's what you
do your work on,
because you don't want
to be messing around
once you start doing
the perturbation sums,
because it's ugly enough.
So you want to simplify this as
much as possible, and you do.
And so the purpose is this
is delta v of minus 3.
This is delta v of plus 3.
This is delta v of minus 1.
This is delta v of plus 1.
You arrange the terms
according to selection rules,
and so what you
end up getting is
Q cubed is equal to this
thing, to the 3/2 times
a cubed plus 3 a n plus 3
a dagger n plus 1 plus a.
OK, the algebra is
tedious, pretty simple.
And what you usually
want to do is
have the thing that changes
the vibrational quantum
number after the thing
that preserves it,
because then it's easy just
to write down these matrix
elements just by inspection.
OK?
You could do it the
other way around.
It's more complicated if you
put the n first and then the a,
but it's up to you.
So these then are
what you work on,
and now we start doing
non-degenerate perturbation
theory.
The first thing
you do is you want
to know, well, what is
the first-order correction
to the energy?
And if this is Q to the 3rd
power, then this, that's 0.
So you like 0's,
but in this case,
you're kind of
disappointed, because you
don't know what the sign
of the coefficient of Q
to the 3rd power is from
any experiment or at least
any experiment at the
level we've described.
When we introduce rotation
as well as vibration,
there will be something
that reports the sign
of the coefficient of Q 3rd.
So now, we're stuck, and
we have to start doing
all of this second-order stuff.
OK.
Well, we have this
bQ to the 3rd power,
and so we get squares
of the matrix element.
So we get a b squared.
We get this thing
to the 3rd power,
because we're squaring
the matrix element, so
this bunch of constants.
And then, you get a
matrix element v prime,
some operator v, then we
get an energy denominator.
Now, there's a lot
of symbols, but we
want to simplify things as much
as possible, hc omega times v
minus v prime.
So this is matrix element
squared over an energy
denominator, and what
you really want to know
is what is the quantum number
dependence of everything?
OK, so the operator here
is either Q dagger cubed,
Q dagger--
I'm sorry, a cubed, a times n,
a dagger n plus 1, or a dagger
cubed.
And so we know how to write
all of these matrix elements,
trivially, no work.
Once we've simplified
here, it's really trivial
to write the squared
matrix element.
OK, so we do it, and
so we arrange things
according to delta v
and we have delta v
of plus 3, plus 1,
minus 1, and minus 3.
And so what we get from the
square of the matrix element
a dagger cubed, we get v
plus 1, v plus 2, v plus 3,
and we also have an
energy denominator.
And we're going to get for
this one 1 over minus 3,
because the initial
quantum number is v,
and the second quantum
number, v prime, is v plus 3,
and so we get a minus 3
in the energy denominator.
And then the plus 1,
that comes out to be--
I've got it in a different
order in my notes--
that comes out to be 9, v plus
1, v plus 2, v plus 1 squared,
and the energy denominator
for this is 1 over minus 1.
OK.
Then, we have the--
I'm going to skip this one-- we
have the matrix element here,
and that's going to be
v minus 1, v minus 2.
Remember, we're
squaring these things.
So that's why we don't have
those square roots anymore,
and we have an energy
denominator 1 over 3.
OK, now advice--
you don't like this,
and you want to
minimize your effort.
And so it turns out that
if you take the terms
with the equal and opposite
energy denominators
and combine them,
simplifications occur.
One of the things
you can see is you're
going to have a v
cubed here, and you're
going to have a v cubed here.
They're going to cancel,
because we have a 1 over minus 3
and a 1 over plus 3.
So you get an algebraic
simplification
when you take these terms
pairwise and combine them.
Now, you're never in your
life going to do this,
but if you did do it,
this is how you end up
with formulas which are simple.
They're horrible getting
there, unless you
know how to get there.
So now there's a rule.
So if the perturbation
is Q to the n,
then the highest-order
term involves v plus 1/2
to the n minus 1.
The reason for that is
in the matrix element
the highest-order term is
v plus 1/2 to the 3 over 2,
and then you square it,
you get to the 3rd power,
and then the highest-order
term cancels.
So we know that if we're
dealing with Q to the 3rd power,
we're going to get a
term v plus 1/2 squared.
If we're dealing with
Q to the 4th power,
well, then we get
something from second order
from the first-order
correction to the energy
a delta v of one matrix element.
What we've done is square
it, and we get v plus 1/2
squared also.
OK and the off-diagonal
matrix element,
we're going to get
from the highest order
from the off-diagonal
is v plus 1/2 cubed.
So one of the things that
is great about the algebra
is with a little
bit of practice,
you know how to organize things,
and if you do the algebra,
you collect the
highest-order terms.
Then, there's that kind
of cascading result,
and you get the lowest-order
terms in simplified form.
So this is irrelevant,
but this is how you do it,
if you're a professional.
So with these results,
we can determine
the relationship between
these molecular constants.
Where did I put them?
Oh, probably on this board.
No.
Oh yeah, it's right here.
So we have omega e,
omega e xe, omega e ye,
and we have then
the relationships
between these things
which you measure
and these things that
you want to know.
So the stuff you want
to know is encoded
in the spectrum in a not
particularly complicated way--
it's just not a very
interesting way,
but you have to do it
in order to get it.
OK, so I've got just
a few minutes left,
but I want to get to the
really interesting stuff.
So if you have some
expression for the potential,
it's easy to go and get the
expression for the energy
levels and the wave functions.
And you can use the vector
picture or the wave function
picture.
It doesn't matter,
and so this is
enough to do the spectroscopy.
It tells you not only
where are the energies,
but because some
transitions are supposed
to be weak because of
the dipole selection rule
or whatever, it
says, well, there
are some transitions that
have borrowed intensity.
It also tells you--
suppose we make a coherent
superposition state at T
equals 0 using a short
pulse, and suppose
in the linear combination
of zero-order states,
there is only one
that is bright.
And so then it
tells us, if we know
how to go from basis
states to eigenstates,
we can go backwards, and
we can write the expression
for the T equals 0
superposition in terms
of some sum over psi v0 cv.
And if we have
this, as long as we
are writing a superposition
in terms of eigenstates,
we know immediately
how to get to this,
and then we've got
all the dynamics.
So the perturbation
theory enables
you to say, if I want to
work in the time domain,
I know what to do.
You're going to get--
in the time domain--
you're going to get a
signal that oscillates,
and it oscillates at frequencies
corresponding to energy level
differences divided by h bar.
And so what frequencies will
appear in the Fourier transform
of the spectrum, and what are
the amplitudes of those Fourier
components?
You can calculate
all of those stuff.
It all comes from
perturbation theory.
These mixing coefficients you
get by perturbation theory.
And remember, if you have
a transformation that
diagonalizes the Hamiltonian
that the eigenstates correspond
to, the columns of T
dagger, and the expression
of the zero-order states,
in terms of the eigenstates,
corresponds to either
the columns of T
or the rows of T dagger.
So once you do the
perturbation theory,
you can go to the
frequency domain
spectrum with
intensities and frequency
or the time domain spectrum
with amplitude and frequencies.
It's all there.
This is a complete tool.
It's the kind of
tool that you can
use for an enormous
number of problems,
and so you'd better get
comfortable with perturbation
theory, because the people
who aren't comfortable
can't do anything
except talk about it.
But if you want to actually
solve problems, especially
problems on an exam,
you want to know
how to use perturbation theory.
And you also want to know
how to read and construct
the relevant notation
in the vector picture,
because a vector picture
and the matrix picture
is the one where you
see the entire structure
of the problem.
And you can decide on how you're
going to organize your time
or what are the important
things that I'm going
to get from this analysis.
And so it's much better than
the Schrodinger picture,
because with the
Schrodinger picture,
you're just solving a
differential equation and one
problem at a time, whereas
with the matrix picture,
you're solving all
problems at once.
This is really a
wonderful thing,
and so that's why I'm
taking a very different path
from what is in the textbooks.
Your wonderful
textbook McQuarrie
does not do second-order
perturbation theory.
So nothing you want can be
calculated, unless you're
dealing with NMR, and you're
dealing with magnetic dipole
transitions.
And then, you can get
a lot of good stuff
from first-order
perturbation theory,
and you can avoid second
order until you grow up.
OK, I'm done.
I'll be talking about
rigid rotor next time,
and I will be talking about it
also in an unconventional way.